Speaker 1: here is something really interesting.
This is sort of related to the Marjorie Taylor
Greene Twitter and Facebook ban about what
was it like a month ago, three weeks ago,
something like that. I played a video clip for
you of Republican Congressman Dan Crenshaw,
who is a Trump guy. There's no doubt about
it. Dan Crenshaw is a Trump guy criticizing
the so-called Freedom Caucus of the House of
Representatives, which is a very Trump caucus,
saying These people are performance artists
and they are not. At the end of the day,
really the people that voted in support of
what Donald Trump wanted. This conflict between
Crenshaw and people like Marjorie Taylor Greene is
now like two trains barreling towards each other.
Because after this ban stunt from Marjorie Taylor
Greene and by stunt, I mean how she reacted to it.
Dan Crenshaw. As much more directly attacked her
and Marjorie Taylor Greene has now turned on him,
so let let me kind of explain it all to you. In
the immediate on me, get this all looking correct
here. In the immediate aftermath of her being
banned. Dan Crenshaw posted that Marjorie scoffed
at the notion of supporting anti-censorship
legislation is indicative of her true intent to
remain a victim. She doesn't want solutions,
and she doesn't care if you get censored.
She just wants to be a victim so she can keep
asking you for campaign donations. It's a scam.
Dan Crenshaw is 110 percent correct here.
He's 110 percent correct now. Understand
that what he was advocating for was seriously
heavy regulation of platforms like Twitter and
Facebook. So he is a hypocrite in the sense that
he is part of the party that says we should do
as little regulation of business as possible.
Regulating businesses socialism. He's talked
on The Joe Rogan Show about his belief about what
socialism is, and it's a very, very wrong belief.
So he was ignoring his so supposedly sincerely
held beliefs about a light government regulatory
touch, saying, Let's regulate these companies.
But he is correctly pointing out that Marjorie
Taylor Greene had the opportunity to support
anti-censorship as they call it legislation,
and that what she is doing is a scam to raise
campaign contributions. He's completely right.
He also posted, I think this is on his Instagram.
Hey, by the way, Marjorie, isn't this you?
This was the moment you went for a few drinks.
Instead of voting on the NDAA before bringing up
missed votes, you might want to check your own
record. This is after Marjorie Taylor Greene
said to Dan Crenshaw, Hey, you've missed votes as
well. This is a picture of Marjorie Taylor Greene
sitting at a bar when apparently voting was taking
place on NDAA. The substance of this matters less
than the fact that two pro-Trump Republicans.
That's what they are. Are fighting with each
other. Crenshaw went on to say, Hey Marjorie, if
suggesting we should Paula follow Trump policy
instead of Biden mandates makes you mad, then you
might be a Democrat or just an idiot. So very big
attacks Trump on Trump violence. Crenshaw then
posted, Guess some people woke up today and tried
to compete for biggest idiot on the internet.
Then going on to say seeing a lot of manufactured
outrage by some people lately, they're worried
they're losing their grip on your attention
because they are. They lash out in the hopes
you'll pay attention to them. Kind of sad, really.
Dan Crenshaw is totally right here about
what Marjorie Taylor Greene is doing.
These are what we call what I call FSB's
attention seeking behaviors. And Crenshaw
went on to say, and Marjorie, instead
of playing the victim about censorship,
maybe use your position as a legislator to help
pass legislation against censorship. Luckily,
I've already done all the hard work for
you and drafted a bill that would change
Section 230 to prohibit political censorship. One
a copy co-sponsor before I introduce it, or do you
prefer to keep up with petty and childish
attacks? Your call? Marjorie Taylor Greene
completely then losing it on Dan Crenshaw saying
Dan Crenshaw is posting creepy stalking pictures
of me, referring to the picture from the bar
and harassing me to co-sponsor his Big Tech bill
that he says stop censorship, but his bill
actually gives more protection to online porn
companies. Very, very weird thing
to post. And then lastly, she wrote.
No thanks, Dan. We need to get rid of porn.
I am busy reading other Republicans stop Big
Tech censorship bills. Gosh, and to think all
of this started when I just disagreed with him,
when he said FEMA should be doing mass COVID
testing and working in hospitals, all I said is,
no, we don't want FEMA doing any of that. And
hospitals need to hire back unvaccinated health
care workers. Then poof, I'm kicked off Twitter.
Did I offend Dan's globalist friends at the World
Economic Forum? This is this is really great. I
have to tell you guys I wish that the left was
was more competently preparing for 2022 and 2024.
I think the left may be heading for a disaster.
But Trump is fighting with Trumpists is a really,
really good thing. And just to remind everybody,
here's that original clip where Dan Crenshaw
seemed to start expressing some disdain
for the grifters like Marjorie Taylor Greene
and others without naming them directly.
Speaker 2: Remember this supporting these
two actually other veterans in Morgan's race?
There's other front, so I support these two well
because I've been in Congress for almost three
years now, and there's two types of numbers in
Congress, right? There's performance artists,
there's legislators and performance artists
are the ones that get all the attention.
The ones you think are more conservative
because they know how to say slogans real. Well,
you know how to recite the lines that
they know that our voters want to hear.
Let me tell you something. In the
first two years of Trump's presidency,
the Republicans were in control when every single
time they were voting on Donald Trump's agenda.
What do you think was at the top of that list
winning with Trump and who do you think was at the
bottom? Well, a lot of names you would recognize
were at the bottom of that list of names you would
recognize are at the top of that list. Number two,
probably going to make you created a little bit.
Adam Kinzinger 02 it troubles 99 percent. He was
Speaker 1: number two. So the important thing the
important takeaway here is that these are all
Trumpists in some sense. Marginally. Marjorie
Taylor Greene is a Trumpist in the way that she
has completely abandoned even talking about policy
spreads, lies, disinformation. It's kind of like
the cartoonish, weaponized Trumpist. But what Dan
Crenshaw reminds us is that a lot of the people
that we on the left might say they're not that
bad. Liz Cheney Wow. She said. Biden, really one
that's that's really great. Adam Kinzinger Hey,
he was willing to vote to convict Trump on
impeachment. I'm sorry to you. He was willing
to support impeachment of Donald Trump. He's a
member of the House, not the Senate. And we say,
Wow, these people are kind of more reasonable.
They vote with Trump all the time, all the time.
And so they are not our political allies. Dan
Crenshaw is absolutely right. Let's hope that this
Trump and Trump civil war continues because the
left needs something to help us along this year.